you bought a huge canister aluminum can
of super hot red peppers three kilograms
worth and you hung them from two strings
from the ceiling because you don't want
anyone to get your super hot red peppers
and you wanted to know what's the
tension in both of these strings if this
is the angle that the strings make
with the ceiling what are these two
tensions this problem's hard this
problem's spicy this is a spicy tension
problem let's start with something a
little more mild and we'll work our way
up to this to see how this works we're
going to do that because
even though this one seems very
difficult and easier problems seem much
different from it the process that you
use to figure out the answer is always
the same so i'm going to try to show you
that you shouldn't get distracted even
though the details are different the
process the overall strategy is the same
let's start with something a little
easier let's start with this a nice red
apple let's say this apple is three
kilograms so we can keep the same number
three kilogram apple hanging from a
string we want to know what's the
tension in the rope well this one's easy
the way you solve it is the way you
solve all these problems so even though
it's easy we're going to go through the
entire process you can see how it works
and it won't take long we draw the
forces the force of gravity is exerted
on this apple
because it's always exerted on
everything near the earth and it's mg
then we've got a tension force and the
tension does not push you can't push
with a rope you can pull with a rope so
this tension force
points upward i'll call it t
that's always the first step you draw
your force diagram and now you use
newton's second law for either the
horizontal direction or the vertical
direction or both if you have to so
we're going to use newton's second law
which looks like this
the acceleration in a certain direction
equals the net force in that direction
divided by the mass which direction do
we pick it's pretty obvious here we'll
pick the vertical direction because
there are no forces in the horizontal
direction
and i'll plug in the acceleration if
this apple's just hanging here and not
moving then it's not accelerating it's
just sitting here unless this was like
an elevator or a rocket ship that had
acceleration upward you could do that
you'd plug in that acceleration but if
it's just hanging from the ceiling at
rest this acceleration is going to be
zero
that's going to equal the net force
we've got tension upward to figure out
what goes here
like we draw this force diagram for a
reason this isn't just like
happy fun painting time over here where
you this is a strategy we draw these
forces because this lets us know what we
plug into newton's second law for the
net force
if it's not on here i don't put it up
here and if it is on here i have to put
it in here if it's in that direction so
tension is vertical and this is the
vertical direction for the net force so
i put tension in here i'm going to call
upward positive that means i make this
tension positive and how about mg over
here mg points down so i do minus mg
and i divide by the mass
well
now i just solve for the tension so this
is the process you draw your force
diagram you use newton's second law and
then you try to solve for the force that
you want in this case is the tension so
i multiply both sides by m i still zero
on the left-hand side so zero equals t
minus mg
and if i solve this for t
i get something that might not be all
that surprising i just get that the
tension is equal to mg and you might be
like well duh
i could have done that with that was
like way more trouble than it had to be
i mean you just knew it was mg this
tension just has to balance gravity so
it's just mg why did we go through all
this trouble and the reason is i mean it
is equal to mg but it won't always be
equal to mg
so if you want to know what to do when
it's not equal to mg you have to know
how to use this process well
why would it not be equal to mg we'll
imagine this imagine i had say two
tensions up here or let's start with
this let's say i just pull down on the
rope so i just come over here and
someone
or someone pulls down on the apple let's
say someone just pulls down the apple
with an extra five newtons
right pulling this apple which pulls
this string which makes it tighter what
would i do in that case well i've got
one more force here in my force diagram
i just add that
so that's five newtons it's pointing
downward so when i come over here to my
net force i've got to subtract five
newtons because that's pointing downward
and now i do my algebra just as before i
multiply both sides by m
i'll have another minus 5 newtons here
and then when i solve for t i'll add mg
to both sides and i'll add 5 newtons to
both sides and so this would be my force
so with numbers what are we going to get
the mass was 3 so we'll have 3 kilograms
times the acceleration due to gravity
it's 9.8 but to make the numbers nice
let's just round to 10 for now 10 meters
per second squared that way we don't get
lost in details and decimals
so plus
5 newtons so it's mg when it's just
hanging there but if there's extra
forces it won't be mg in this case
with a 5 newton force downward it's
going to be 30 plus 5 so it's going to
be 35 newtons
so it's equal to mg in the easiest
possible case but if there's extra
forces it won't be equal to that
also if there was another rope pulling
up in the same spot as the first rope
now i'd have two tensions pulling up
now i've got another tension force
pulling up this way
so what would i do now i'd have to add
another t i'd have plus t
well t plus t is just 2t
so i'd have a 2t here i'd have a 2t here
to solve for t i just have to do 35
newtons divided by 2. so you can start
making these harder and harder and
harder
and you could do that by adding extra
ropes or adding forces down
and you might convince yourself
erroneously you have to do something new
but you don't you still just draw your
force diagram then you go to newton's
second law you put those forces in
carefully you solve for what you want to
know and if this is confusing why is it
35 over 2 it kind of makes sense the
total downward force is 35 newtons
because this is 30 newtons
of weight here
we've got 35 newtons downward the total
upward force has to be 35 and if these
strings are attached at the same point
they're both going to bear the same
amount of weight they have to total up
to 35 so you just get 35 over 2 amongst
each of them because they each bear half
the weight
so that was one of the easiest problems
we turned it into a little bit of a
harder problem it gets even harder if we
add an angle remember those jalapenos
were at an angle we got to do this we
got to do one at an angle so you've got
a chalkboard hanging from two strings
one string's horizontal one string is up
here at an angle what do you do now it's
easy to convince yourself you got to try
something new or to go for a new
strategy but you don't you solve this
the same way we're going to draw our
forces
we've still got a force of gravity down
so this force of gravity is just mg
and for consistency's sake let's say the
mass of this chalkboard is also three
kilograms
all right what else do i have i'm gonna
have a tension that points up into the
right it does not it doesn't point this
way tension doesn't push tension pulls
so this tension's gotta pull this way
we'll call this t one
this is a t one
and over on my force diagram it would
look like this i'd have a t one that
points
something like that
so here's my t1
i'll put it right here t1
and i've got one more force now i've got
this horizontal force here again it does
not push this is a rope it can only pull
so it pulls to the left i'll call this
t2 so on my force diagram i would have
t2
that's it those are all my forces i
don't have a normal force sometimes
people want to draw people are so used
to they're always being normal force
they're like normal force right and it's
like no there's no surface touching this
chalkboard it's just hanging by strings
the only force keeping it up would be
the vertical component of this t1 so
this is it these are the only forces
we've got what do you do after that same
as the apple problem we go to newton's
second law and we say that the
acceleration
will be the net force divided by the
mass which direction do we pick it's not
quite as obvious here we've got forces
vertically and horizontally so here's my
advice
look for something that you know in this
case i know the mass is 3 kilograms and
i know the acceleration due to gravity
or the magnitude of it 9.8 but in this
case 10. since i know this force
remember this force is just 30 newtons
because 3 times 9.8 or 3 times 10
meters per second squared is just 30
newtons since i know this force it's a
vertical force i know something about
that direction i'm just going to start
with that direction because i already
know something about it so i'm going to
do a in the y direction f in the y
direction we'll start with the vertical
direction if you make a mistake and you
pick the wrong direction it's not the
end of the world just pick the other
direction i mean there's only two to
worry about so if you screw one up just
go on to the next one it's not that big
of a deal all right acceleration
vertically again let's say this is at
rest just hanging from these strings so
we don't have to worry about any
acceleration although if there was you
would just plug that acceleration in
here it's not that
not that much harder of a problem
zero equals all right what do we got we
need to put our vertical forces up top
i know this one 30 me 30 newtons
downward i'm gonna have negative 30
newtons because those 30 newtons point
down and i'm going to consider
downward as a negative upward as
positive
this is really just mg i could have
wrote it as negative mg
what else do i have i've got t1 t1
points up but i can't add all of t1 here
because it doesn't all point up i can
only add all of t1 if t1 pointed
straight upward but it doesn't part of
it points up so this part of t1 points
to the right
pull to the right this part of t1 pulls
up it's this component right here that's
going to be the component that actually
causes this chalkboard to stay up that
keeps it from falling down
because that's the part that's fighting
gravity we'll call this t1 in the y
direction we'll call this t1 in the x
direction so you need to add plus t 1 in
the y direction
and that's it those are the only two
forces that are vertical t 1 x is not
vertical that's horizontal and this t 2
is horizontal so i've included t 1 y and
mg those are the only two forces that
are vertical so now i divide by my mass
i can multiply both sides by mass m
times zero is still zero
i get zero equals negative thirty
newtons plus t one y
and now we have to figure out okay like
t one y
t one y has to equal what i can solve
this for t one y
i add thirty to both sides i'm gonna get
t one y equals positive 30 newtons
and that makes sense i mean
this t1y is the only component that's
balancing out gravity we don't have to
balance because there's no acceleration
vertically
so this t1y has to be the exact same
size as the force of gravity i drew it
it's not proportional here sorry about
that i should have drawn it with this
component exactly the same length as
this component because they have to be
the same they have to cancel
but that just tells me t1y i want to
know what t1 is
how do i solve for what t 1 is and what
t 2 is
these are what i want to figure out what
are the tensions i don't just want the
component i want the tension and so
now i say that this component t 1 y
is going to be related to the total t1
and it's related through this angle here
so i can say that t1y whatever this
angle is right here
remember we can use trigonometry and we
can say that
sine
theta is going to be the opposite side
over the hypotenuse
and in this case the opposite side to
this angle opposite is t 1 y
it's going to be t 1 y divided by the
hypotenuse side is the total tension so
that's always the total magnitude of the
force in this case we're calling that t1
so i want to solve for t1 so i'm going
to if i multiply both sides by t1 i'll
get t1 times sine theta and then i
divide both sides by sine theta i'll end
up with t1 equals
t1 in the y direction divided by sine
theta
i know t1 in the y direction that was 30
degrees or sorry not 30 degrees that was
30 newtons
so i've got 30 newtons that's my force
upward this vertical component right
here had to be 30 newtons because it had
to balance gravity
divided by sine of the angle but what is
this angle we know this angle is 30
and you could probably convince yourself
if i draw a triangle this way let's try
to figure out
we want to figure out what this angle is
right here
because that's what this angle is here
so if this is 30 and that's 90 then this
has to be 60
and if that's 60 and this is 90
then this has to be 30. so this angle is
30 degrees right here
so that's 30 degrees
so this
angle right here which is this angle
right here has to be 30 so when i'm
taking my sine i'm taking my sine of 30
degrees and i get 30 newtons divided by
sine of 30 and sine of 30 is one half
so 0.5 so i get that this is 60 newtons
and that might seem crazy you might be
like wait a minute
t1 is 60 newtons
60 newtons the weight of this chalkboard
is only 30 newtons how in the world can
the
tension in this rope be 60 newtons
i mean if we just hung it by a single
string
if we just hung this chalkboard by a
single string over the center of mass
you just get a tension of 30 newtons how
can this be 60 newtons and the reason is
this part has got to be 30 newtons we
know that because it has to balance
gravity
but that's only part of the total
tension
so if the total tension if part of the
total tension is 30 all of the tension's
got to be more than 30 and in this case
it's 60 newtons so that's why it's a
larger in this case because it's at an
angle so this component has to equal
gravity and this total amount has to be
bigger than that so that its component
is equal to gravity
alright how do we figure out t2 well
you don't invent a new strategy we keep
going we just gonna say that the
acceleration in the horizontal direction
is the net force in the horizontal
direction divided by the mass so we
still stick with newton's second law
even when we want to find this other
force
this force is horizontal so it makes
sense that we're going to use newton's
second law for the horizontal direction
again if this chalkboard is not
accelerating the acceleration is zero so
i'll draw a line here to keep my
calculations separate
equals net force in the x direction okay
now i'm going to have t 1 in the x
direction so this is going to be t 1 and
the x
so i'll have t 1
in the x direction that's positive
because it points right and i'm going to
consider right word positive minus t 2
all of t2 i don't have to break t2 up t2
points completely in the horizontal
direction
and i divide that by the mass
and well i can multiply both sides by
mass i'd get 0 equals
t1 in the x direction
minus excuse me minus t2
so if i solve this for t2
i'm going to get the t2 if i add t2 to
both sides i get the t2 just equals
t1 in the x direction but how big is t1
in the x direction we know t1 is 60
newtons
we know t1 in the y direction
this piece here was 30 newtons how big
is this piece well we can use instead of
sine now we can use cosine
so if i use cosine i can get the cosine
theta
which is 30 degrees here because this
angle here is 30. cosine of 30 would be
the adjacent
that's this t1x so it's adjacent over
the hypotenuse the hypotenuse is t1 and
we know t1 t1 was 60.
so i can solve for t1x and i get that t1
in the x direction
if i multiply both sides by 60 newtons
this is 60 newtons i get the t1 in the x
direction would be 60 newtons
times cosine of 30
and the cosine of 30 is
cosine of 30 is root 3 over 2 so i get
60 newtons
times root 3 over 2
which means that t1 in the x direction
is 60 over 2 would be 30 so this is 30
root 3 newtons and that's what i can
bring up here this is t1x
so since that's t1x i can say t1x right
here
is 30 root 3 newtons
and by newton's second law in the
horizontal direction that's what t2 had
to equal
so t2 equals 30 root 3 newton so we
figured it out t2 equals
30 root 3 newtons and that shouldn't be
surprising this force here in order to
make it so that there's no acceleration
horizontally just has to equal this
force here those are the only two
horizontal forces we knew t1x was 30
root three that's what we found so that
means t2 also has to be 30 root 3 to
make it so that these forces are
balanced in the horizontal direction all
right so we did it we figured out t1 60
newtons we figured out t2 30 root 3
newtons now we're ready now we can
figure out
the super hot jalapeno problem we'll do
that in the next video